à mon niveau de l'époque mais j'étais
incapable d'attaquer une chose aussi
forte et puissante qu'un texte comme
celui-ci je vous propose maintenant de
on a fait connaissance et je pense qu on
vous retrouvera régulièrement dans cette
émission si dieu nous prêtons missile
après celui ci est là nous prédit on va
on va entraîner dans la connaissance
d'orlando on va entendre
je suis morte qui est un premier texte
très fort
chantée par aïda sanchez vous êtes
accompagné au piano par frédéric
marchand et christelle boizanté orlando
e
je suis morte de rire je me souviens pas
pourquoi je vais par le hiv je suis
morte du sida suis morte de faim suis
morte de faim bâti noyer d'identité je
suis morte de froid un soir d'hiver je
n'avais pas de toi je suis morte n'a
rien morte de jalousie je ne sais pas
comment mourir sur sur cette terre
encore un luxe supplémentaire
comment mourir sur
sur cette terre encore un luxe
supplémentaire
on
je suis mort d'être noir tu supportes
d'espoir je suis morte d'être moi je me
suis suicider c'était une simple idée
qui m'a assassiné
je suis morte d'amour capote oublier
jument décapité
si dans deux vélos tombée dans
l'escalier je suis morte crucifié
comment mûri sur sur cette période
plémentaires comment mourir sur sur
cette terre encore luxe supplémentaire
je suis mort torture et je suis morte
d'oubli et je suis morte dans mon lit
j'suis mort d'une overdose je suis morte
de froid
j'ai couru à trois dents je suis mort
telle bavure je suis mort d'une brown
je suis morte des fois je suis morte au
combat je suis mortes lapidées je suis
morte violée
comment nourrir sur
sur c'est peut-être comme alex
supplémentaires comment comment mourir
sur cette terre encore
un but supplémentaire
je mords tcherno pire
je suis morte match folle
je suis morte de honte je suis morte
solitaire je suis morte à la guerre
j'suis mort d'homme sans appel comment
vous hri sûr
je sais de terre encore
à luxe supplémentaire comment comment
mourir sur cette terre un corps à luxe
supplémentaire
mais